États-Unis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le Canada et
la reine du sport olympique canadien
[Applaudissements]
Penny Oleksiak a décroché une médaille
d'or 2 médaille d'argent et 4 de bronze
en seulement 2 Olympiades
la torontoise de 20 ans maintenant Clara
UGC qui ont remporté 6 médailles chacune
à la sortie de la piscine Penny Oleksiak
rayonnait modeste elle est heureuse de
pouvoir partager son exploit avec ses
coéquipiers
ce qui est encore plus exceptionnel
c'est ton retour où se met à Tokyo après
les années difficiles qui ont suivi les
jeux de Rio aucune médaille en épreuves
individuelles lors des grands
rendez-vous internationaux avec une
forme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les succès grandiose de Penny Oleksiak
vont rejaillir sur la natation
canadienne est inspiré une nouvelle
génération c'est fantastique pour
l'avenir du Spar s'inspire bien sur les
jeunes et moins jeunes à simply mais
particulièrement la la relève il va
certainement avoir des Alexia qui vont
se développer au fil des années qui vont
être sur des
[Musique]
Canadiennes déjà pris goût à la victoire
6 médailles à Tokyo
en cette journée historique pour le
sport canadien la jeune équipe
exceptionnel de nageuse promet d'être
encore mieux préparé plus fort en 2024 à
peine à 3 ans à Paris ça promet il sait
qu'il pleut au Canada